this honest trailer is brought to you by
tales of zadia the dragon prince
role-playing game available now at tales
of zaydia.com
[Music]
in a world where the only thing more
boring than someone telling you about
their dreams is someone telling you
about their dungeons and dragons
campaign one show will try to make those
dreams a little wetter
[Music]
critical roles legend of vox machina
if you thought d was a lot to absorb
strap in for an adaptation of a twitch
stream of thousands of hours of play
sessions put together by a group of
nerdy ass voice actors asking the most
pressing question of our time what a
tolkien
all brought to life by fans willing to
toss a coin to their twitchers in the
hopes that they'll pull off what hasn't
been done since clue and successfully
adapt a tabletop game to screen unless
you're secretly into the battleship
movie
any ouija heads out there maybe dungeons
and dragons y2k how about the tom hanks
one why are you so impatient
because i love you and i want you to
forgive me yeah that's real and it's
spectacular
ronnie you can't it's a trap
tj what am i doing here
pretty dark
grab an ale and meet box machina a
ragtag crew of mercs so horny and quippy
joss whedon is suing them for vibe
infringement not everything's a trap you
twitch let's do this
they're scanlin the horny boy with a
tragic past who's master of the [__]
percy a fancy lad with a tragic past who
found himself in a fantasy setting and
asked why not try gun vex and facts
twins with a tragic past and the power
to make you constantly call the show vex
are backs mocking up by mistake facts
forms backs facts box facts vex vox max
box facts max vox max grog an idiot with
a tragic past he dum-dum stupid you are
hereby under house arrest how can you
arrest a house pike a cleric with a
tragic past and a direct line to dnd
jesus but since that's too powerful they
just sidelined her for half the season
i'm not going
i have to do this alone caleb a tree
hugger with a tragic past who's also a
jewish princess filled with ashari i'm
supposed to lead someday funny
she doesn't look jewish and a bear with
what i can only assume is a tragic past
a well-adjusted bear just takes his
chances in the woods right together
they'll win glory riches and fame by
uncovering an ancient secret the beast
is a blue dragon sire how do we fight it
there's no simple way to kill a dragon
did gilmore give you any insight on how
to kill this thing the only way to kill
a dragon is to hit it in the throat the
neck you see that no one thought to try
that before i mean dragons are like 20
throat is there no roadhouse cooler
class in this edition
swayze man now that's a character with
high charisma
take a chance and roll the dice on a
series aimed at everyone from fans of
invincible defense of buying sorts from
the skymall catalog
as bezos continues his getting back in
my bully's investment spree with plenty
of catnip for die hards while sneaking
so much actual d d into the script
you'll feel like you're eating lunch
alone in eighth grade again from
references to spell cooldown rules and i
think i can only do it like once a day
having to shop for supplies before an
expedition we will take all the holy
water you've got you're looking at it
you're annoying buddy who comes up with
a super long name and expects everyone
to use it i am lord percival frederick
steinver muscle kolowski dorella iii the
uselessness of bards what if i lure the
guards away from the house
good one come on real ideas only to
revealing the true big bad evil guy of
every single rpg of all time
doors it's just a damn door
it's locked open the door it's not a
door
it's a thing of evil
stop these hinges are rusted
not everything has to be a puzzle guys
we've been playing for six hours
straight and i want to go home
so gather around for a series that
recognizes the franchise potential of d
d as an infinite story generator set in
hundreds of cool unique worlds this one
just happens to have lots of dick jokes
in it meticulously crafted dick jokes by
some of the greatest scribes in all the
land oh man mercer hey i love your best
thank you you uh you weren't talking
about my show were you uh just the usual
amount good otherwise you can expect
what my wife calls a good old-fashioned
paducah river strangle and then i'll
leave your body in orbit when bezos
takes me to space dude
i'm kidding it's me matt mercer the
nicest person in the world who is
definitely not a murderer anything else
while i'm here two things if you don't
mind where do all of your amazing ideas
come from well as a teenager i was
bitten by a radioactive van with a naked
wizard painted on the side also it never
hurts to have a little buzz going what's
the other thing uh i think i'm finally
ready to challenge you epic voice guy to
epic voice guy ah a worthy opponent you
know the rules best how do you want to
do this wins very well winner reads the
starring section
how do you want to do this how do you
want to do this how do you want to do
this how do you want to do this how do
you want it dang it rolling that one
well played sir you can take it from
here
starring
lesner vengeance for my family with a
pocket full of shells sharpest knife in
the drawer
elf with a shelf
this gnome gives dome
make like a tree and get out of here
cool youth pastor sister so you have a
twin sister your feelings have not
betrayed her too
and hey we saw you from across the
tavern we really dig your vibe
d and d's nuts
hey you know if amazon doesn't play ball
keeping such a cool show around all good
this crew can actually crowdfund six
seasons in a movie and a follow a video
game a live action movie and a making up
documentary
what's it like being loved this much
this honest trailer is brought to you by
tales of zadia the dragon prince role
playing game available now at tales of
zadia dot com what tales will you tell
dagger dagger dagger
i like big butts and i cannot lie
come on to the coast we'll get together
have a few laughs